listen you showed yourself and mr. Bob
Lord Bob are in the family together is
this the first time you've been in film
together but the first time you've been
on screen together yes yes we were in
Stardust together and I was so excited
to be in a movie with Robert De Niro and
then I realized I actually didn't get to
work with Robert De Niro because we've
had no sings together then we did New
Year's Eve and again I was so excited to
be in a movie with him and once again
had no scenes together we would meet on
the red carpet hello nice to see you
you're wonderful in the film so then I
get this script and I said to my agent
you know what if I don't have a scene
with him I am not reading this anyway we
we had some great things together we had
fun we meant to be in Raging Bull was
that just a story
yes actually I was I wasn't meant to be
in Raging Bull no I am I went it was one
of my first interviews I was just
starting out I don't know how my agent
got me in the room with him but he did
and I surprised he doesn't remember me
because I walked in looking like a
hooker it was yeah people look like
hookers people who look like oh there's
some white dresses yeah I got I had I
can't square on this I didn't think I
had a chance you can swear on this and I
say a shot in hell
ready Eunice
no knee apologize sir bulb
one good one there's a terrible song for
charity reading a biography Mike you are
a fan of the older lady now that you put